- My next guest is the
man behind the Vlog Squad,
his YouTube channel has amassed
more than 7 billion views.
Please welcome back to the
show David Dobrik everybody.
What's up man, how are you doing?
- Good, how are you doing?
- I'm doing all right.
Last time you were on the show,
you mentioned that you could
actually see our studio
in Hogwarts from your house.
Can you show us?
- I did.
I did say that you wanna see right now?
- Yes, I do David Dobrik
- Perfect timing now that
we are both stuck at the--
- I know (laughs).
- I have no choice.
Yeah, can you wait (indistinct)?
- Are you in the house by the way?
- You're not at your
studio, where are you?
- Well, I'm at a fake studio
they built in our living room.
So it's like a fake little studio.
Oh my gosh, you can see that's so crazy.
- That's Hogwarts and then
your studio is right there.
- Oh my gosh, you're so close.
- That's why I'm bummed out
that I was only invited once
I could come by at any second.
- I know you got only invited once.
Well, we didn't even get
through our first season
before having the pandemic hit up
and shoot from my house so.
- How is it shooting from your house?
- It was hard when we were in Montana,
I was there for a little over two months
and I didn't know we were
gonna have to work from there.
At first we live so like,
it was very hard because
the internet is not great.
But it ended up I'm back
in LA now in our house
so they built a little
studio, so it's fine now.
- Awesome.
- How's your quarantine been?
- I don't know.
It's kind of like it's
the same thing every day.
I play so many video
games and it's the worst.
I'm becoming like my 16
year old self I think.
(laughs)
Like I'm just an incredible home buddy
and like my friends around
me are now realizing like,
wow, he really likes staying inside
and just being sheltered.
I don't communicate with anybody
I'm really just in my room
just playing video games, but it's fun.
- Last time you were on,
you met Octavia Spencer.
- Last.
- Yeah. So, have you seen her since?
- Oh my god, first off
I cannot say more positive things
about a person like Octavia Spencer,
I had no idea.
I had no idea I was gonna
completely fall in love with her.
I ran into her it was like
an Oscars party or something.
I don't know how I got
in, but I was there.
It was a bunch of different actors
and Octavia was there like in a group
with like, some pretty big
actors like big actors.
And I was like, okay,
I'm gonna go in I'm
gonna say hi to Octavia,
I'm gonna seem so cool
'cause we know each other.
So I go in and I say hi
to her, she says, hi,
she gives me a hug.
it's like best friends reunited.
And I'm like, this is going great
and then I talked to
the other actors there.
And I'm like really flowing
like my conversation is going right now
like I'm doing a good job.
So I'm like, wow,
I'm probably gonna get like
a big movie deal after this
this is nuts, am networking king.
And then as I say goodbye to
Octavia and I'm walking away
and one of the one of the
actors calls me over he goes,
"Hey, can you come here first second?"
And I'm like, Oh my god,
this is my big break.
And he goes, he whispers
in my ear and goes,
"Your fly is down, but
you have the grope."
And I go--
- Oh no.
- I got that the entire time (laughs).
- Oh my God!
- Yeah its the worst.
The entire time I thought
it was being so cool.
I had my fly down the entire time.
- That is like my life in a nutshell.
(laughs)
- It's the worst.
- That's awesome.
- I don't know why these
guys are laughing so much
and it's 'cause they were laughing at me.
- I know.
Well, they probably weren't everybody
does stuff like that happens,
but they--
- I know, I know.
- They at least told you.
I hate it when people don't help people.
- Its the best.
It takes a lot of
courage to tell somebody.
- Yes.
- I actually never had the courage
of telling but like when my
friend has food on their mouth
or like somebody I don't know
like this food on their mouth,
I have such a hard time
going, hey, get the food.
I don't know why but
it's such an embarrassing
conversation to have.
- I am the first person to
tell you if you have a bugger,
your pants aren't zipped,
something's happening.
- Oh, yeah.
- First person I have no,
'cause I want people to tell me
'cause I mean, obviously we're
all human and stuff happens.
- Right, right, right.
- Yeah, yeah.
Natalie, my friend and my assistant
literally always tells me
I have a bugger so she--
- I'm just like you got some get it
and am like (laughs).
- Yeah.
- But if it's a burger it's fine.
We'll move on it'll be fine.
Are you big online shopper?
- Yeah, oh my God, yeah,
I've been getting a
bunch of things from...
So I'm on TikTok a lot.
Let me let me show you a
thing I bought on TikTok.
Okay, here.
Okay, so these are two things
I recently bought from TikTok.
- Okay.
- So this is like a like a pocket
like sword type of thing.
So look, it fits in my pocket.
- Like a saver?
Like a lifesaver?
- Kind of but watch so
like when I'm under attack,
I can just throw it up.
- What the--
- Nuts, nuts.
I'm never in danger anymore Kelly,
I just have this by my side.
- Well, do you know
how to use it? (laughs)
- Not yet, not yet
but my instructor is coming
right after this call.
And then I have this which is really cool.
You put your quarter here
and then it takes a little bit.
- Oh my God (laughs).
- Then a Panda comes out.
Normally he takes the
thing in but he's shy.
He's shy being on a talk show.
- Oh my God (indistinct) over that.
I just like the way he
creeps up like (laughs).
- (indistinct) but there is
a lot of fun stupid things
you could buy on the internet
which I kind of just been
doing because of quarantine so.
Obviously, what else are
we doing other than--
- Right, right.